want to talk about this spy balloon
China says oh look it's just monitoring
the weather is that at all credible
no I don't think it is I mean the
American government made clear they see
this to be an intelligence capability
it's the size of three buses it was
flying at 60 000 feet high that's not
really where you normally get your
weather detail from and also they've
said that this is part of a pattern
where they have seen this happening time
and time again so I think there's no
question that this was definitely
intelligence capability now they've shot
it down the US will be able to work out
exactly what intelligence capabilities
it had on board
you know it almost sounds like something
out of a spy novel doesn't it like know
like a spy balloon you know going over
at the United States there's been
American TV channels that have been put
on balloon watch but you know despite
the kind of gimmicks if you like this is
actually quite serious right
it is serious but I do think it's
important we don't take it out
proportion what it confirms is that
China has a real and meaningful interest
in our capabilities our ability to track
such items but also what it wants to see
on the ground America has nuclear
facilities in Montana for example but we
do have far bigger concerns when it
comes to China I think what it will do
is have for the first time a realization
amongst the American public you know
they were literally sat at home and
could see it outside their bedroom
window that they are being spied on but
actually every day many of us are
walking around with technology such as
Tick Tock in our pockets or Hikvision
cameras and our streets that are also
recording us recording how we walk how
we talk our data our networks our
friends our allies and we know these
details are being sent back to China as
well so whilst it is important actually
there are more meaningful things we
should be concerned about but for the US
what's really useful about this and
blinkum was right to cancel his visit is
that going into this visit the China
would have felt that it was in a
slightly Superior negotiating position
because of the Pelosi visit Taiwan now
actually China will need to show willing
it will need to show meaningful effort
to bring China back on board and for the
US that's a really helpful opportunity
to rebalance the Diplomatic kind of
cards on the table
just want to pick up on what you're
talking about uh with Tick Tock because
it always blows my mind when I look at
you know the number of people who use
tick tock I mean I'm one of them right
you know you use the sort of videos are
we being a bit Sophie get off it stop it
can we be naive are we I'm worried now
we are we are being naive
um so look you know Tick Tock gave
evidence to my committee where they said
that there was no way that individuals
working in China could get access to the
data of Britain's but what we've now
seen is that people working in China for
tick tock hacked into European data so
they could track down the source of a
journalist because what Tick Tock does
is it gives away the data that makes you
most vulnerable who are you friends with
what are your interests what are the
interests you have that you may not want
publicly disclosed who having private
conversations with the locations you go
to there's a reason why China has this
app there's a reason why they're buying
up gay dating apps our data is a key
vulnerability and China is building a
tech totalitarian state on the back of
our data so we have to get far more
serious about protecting ourselves and
yes whilst balloons are an important
diplomatic Spike an opportunity to have
this conversation our bigger concerns
are this data penetration pathway
dependency that China is creating on
Chinese companies uh the way in which
they're intimidating those who sought
refuge in the UK and around the world
these are the bigger concerns that we
should be focused on so that's your
genuine advice then delete tick tock
from your phone
without question I don't have it on my
phone and actually it's fascinating how
often you speak to people and they go
I'm going home tonight to have a serious
conversation with my children it is not
worth having that vulnerability on your
phone and it is the ultimate data source
for anyone with hostile efforts and the
fact is now this isn't just me saying
I'm worried delete it we have evidence
that Tick Tock has been used to track
down sources for journalists everyone
should be concerned about that you know
it feels doesn't it that there's been a
lot of very correct and right focus on
Russia
um because the war in Ukraine and the
activities of Putin but do you think
that perhaps the world has slightly
taken its eye off the ball when it comes
to China
so I think over the last two decades
we've been focused on the threats from
terrorists who behave like States and
unfortunately whilst we actually need to
be looking at the States from States who
behave like terrorists now the issue is
I don't want to criticize too much the
kind of golden era of relations with
China because you can understand why
politicians around the world felt that
was the right approach but whilst they
were investing in those positive
relationships they should have been
planning to fail where they didn't plan
to fail we are now vulnerable so we need
to spend the next 20 to 40 years
focusing on resilience how we make
ourselves protected at home and every
single part of our society now that
doesn't lessen the threat from China and
I am really worried about what's going
to happen in a few weeks before tanks
arrive I'm very worried about Putin's
Mass mobilization however China is a
long-term strategic threat but it
requires significant effort from
government in order to make us resilient
and now while I've got you it's
fascinating to talk to you about um
Foreign Affairs but I have to ask you
about this article by Liz truss as well
4 000 words in the Sunday Telegraph she
blames the left-wing economic
establishment for her downfall she
blames conservative MPS for not
respecting her mandate she blames her
off Communications strategy the office
for Budget responsibility you know the
concept of party polls tanked under her
leadership I just want to know what was
your reaction when you first read uh Liz
trussman's words
so I think uh the best and polite way of
saying it would be that
Recollections do vary
um however fundamentally the markets are
not left they are not woke
unfunded promises are not tenable and
actually the ultimately what ended
listro's Premiership was inability to
manage the party number 10 telling the
minister of the dispatch box one thing
while telling the whips another on a
rather crucial vote it was that
mismanagement of the party that is why
MPS no longer had trust in Liz trust
anymore and that is why her Premiership
ended
it feels like there's a couple of
backseat drivers in the conservative
party at the minute Liz truss and
planning her comeback with more
interventions in the coming week we had
Boris Johnson of course giving an
interview earlier this week as well is
it helpful to the current man in the job
I think um all former Prime Ministers as
back benches have every right to call
for things to try and shape policy but I
think Theresa May has really set the
standard of someone who came back in put
their head down has worked really hard
recognizes that their voice has a real
strength to it to use it at the right
times in the right way and I think they
should model themselves on her